a world health organization team in
china to investigate the origins of the
coronavirus
has ended its mission without definitive
answers to the question
on tuesday the team said the virus most
likely jumped to humans from bats
through an unknown intermediary species
scientists also ruled out the
possibility that the virus
leaked from a lab in the city of wuhan
the stated goal of the world health
organization's wuhan mission was to
identify the origins of the coronavirus
a mission they weren't able to
accomplish
the sars cove ii may have originated
from zoonotic transmission
but the reservoir hosts remain to be
identified
so all the work that has been done on
the virus and trying to
identify its origin continue to point
towards
natural reservoir of these
virus and similar viruses in bad
population
it was here in wuhan just over a year
ago that the world's first cases of the
novel coronavirus were reported
the city of 10 million went on a hard
lockdown for 76 days
only bare essentials were let into the
city
this market believed then to be the
ground zero from where the virus spread
was closed down testing samples were
taken
and it was fenced off wuhan's hospitals
were swamped with patients and the
images of the new deadly disease
traveled around the world
about a year later w.h.o experts arrived
in wuhan
as well as scientific challenges they
faced diplomatic ones
fears from the west that china might try
to whitewash results
and fears from beijing that the mission
might be politicized
scientists spent two weeks in quarantine
leaving just two more for field work
including visits to the wuhan seafood
market and the region's virological
institute
despite not accomplishing the mission's
main goal experts say they were able to
all but eliminate a controversial theory
that the virus had come from a
laboratory in wuhan
the findings suggest that the laboratory
incident hypothesis
is extremely unlikely and
to explain the introduction of the virus
into the human population
but the more pressing question
identifying the intermediary species
that might have transmitted the virus
from bats to humans
remains a work in progress
joining me now one of the members of the
who investigation team epidemiologist dr
fabian linda is from the prestigious
robert koch institute here in berlin
and was assisting the team in china from
right here
dr linda it's a pleasure to have you on
the program now am i correct in
understanding that the team isn't sure
if the coronavirus originated in china
we still have no good evidence for the
place where the spillover has happened
that's right
do you think the team would have had a
better idea
if it had sort of been in china much
earlier
well you know it's it's always the
earlier the better because
the tracks are still fresher however
it's not
too late many of the investigations on
zoonotic diseases
have started much much later than this
one so i think there's still a good
chance
to find out what happened so you are
convinced that we that there will come a
time in our future that we will know
where the coronavirus actually
originated from
this is a very complicated puzzle
especially since this virus causes often
mild
symptoms or no symptoms so it's harder
to follow back the tracks
to the patient zero the index case
however i'm very confident that at some
point we will know
which spat species harbors the right
virus
or the ancestor of all these human
viruses and perhaps we get an idea about
intermediate host which may have played
a role
in the transmission if we will ever find
out
where exactly and how exactly it
happened that's a big question mark
the team spent about one month in china
of which two weeks was spent
in quarantine indoors do you think this
was
sufficient time to try and investigate
the origins of the coronavirus
so the the whole mission is taking much
much longer than that we had discussions
with our chinese colleagues
in the weeks before and the mission
still continues even if the team is not
on site
so um that was the maximum we could
free our time for now and the the
the aim of this first mission was anyway
just to see
what the chinese colleagues have done
already which data are there and where
are the gaps to design the future
studies
so i think the time frame was okay for
that do you think the data that was
shared with the whole team from the
chinese side
uh was sufficient and did you find that
the chinese side were
transparent and helpful in their
dealings
so that the data are not sufficient but
not because
they were hiding them from us it's
because they're not
there yet so this these are these future
study which have to start now
and which will hopefully uh fill the
gaps in that big
puzzle um our impression was
that um we did not get
any evidence for them hiding concrete
data from us we got to saw some of the
raw data
we discussed all the figures and we
really had in-depth
investigations together so the general
gut feeling is a good one
however as everybody knows who has
children you never know what they're
hiding
uh the team also said in the press
conference that
there there could be a possibility of
so-called cold chain transmission
of the virus which is to say that the
virus could have spread
through frozen food packaging for
instance now this is a theory that china
has been putting forward
especially in the past few months would
you say therefore that china has been
vindicated
well so in the in the recent outbreaks
in in china they have
generated good evidence that those
outbreaks
had something to do with the cold chain
and cold chain products
however those are now new outbreaks
starting in the middle of a pandemic
where there are
lots of people around the world who can
contaminate
food packages so the question if that
played a role also at the beginning of
the pandemic is something
we need many more data on and the food
package is nothing where
the virus is born right it's not coming
from a food package that food package
has to be
contaminated either by a symptomatic
human
or by an animal which carries the virus
and so
that will be really difficult to
pinpoint so a little bit too much
attention on the food package
because it's just a vehicle right right
now a lot has been made about the
origins of the coronavirus and there is
of course been a lot of
politics and finger-pointing over it but
just scientifically speaking
do you think it's even important to know
where the coronavirus originated from
i think the most important thing is to
understand how
it emerged because only if we understand
a problem we can
try to take counter measures in the
future to reduce the risk of something
like that
happening again if this event happened
10 meters to the left or to the right to
a border between two countries
really doesn't matter dr fabian
linda thank you so much for putting it
into perspective we leave it there for
the time being thank you so much for
speaking to us
thank you